[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous merci d'être avec
nous pour 100 % Sénat aujourd'hui la
rédaction de Public Sénat vous propose
de suivre deux TBL rondes organisées par
la délégation aux droits des femmes
autour de la question de l'avortement
dans le monde un premier temps d'échange
animé par la sénatrice de lois Sylvie
Valente Leir intitulée des législation
variée en recul dans plusieurs zones du
monde je vous laisse suivre les échanges
et je vous retrouve tout de suite
après au cours des 25 dernières années
si plus de 50 pays ont modifié leur
législation par pour faciliter l'accès
des femmes à l'avortement force est de
constater que dans de nombreuses régions
du monde ce droit est encore restreint
fragile voire inexistant en 2023
l'avortement est autorisé sur demande
sans restriction dans le respect d'un
certain délai dans 75 pays et pour des
raisons socio-économiques dans 1 autres
il est strictement interdit dans 24 pays
autorisés seulement pour sauver la vie
de la mer dans 41 pays et seulement pour
raison de santé dans 49
pays selon le Center for reproductive
rights 41 % des femmes en âge de procréé
dans le monde vivent dans des pays où la
législation sur l'avortement est
restrictive soit près de 700 millions de
femmes toutes les région du monde sont
concerné par l'existence de législation
restrictive en martière de droit à l'IVG
et par l'absence de réelle sécurisation
juridique de ce droit aux États-Unis par
exemple le revirement de jurisprudence
de la Cour suprême en juint 2022 que
citait notre président Dominique Verrien
a entraîné l'adoption de loi très
restrictive voire prohibitive pour les
femmes dans plusieurs États américains
ainsi
l'Alabama et le Missouri ont voté une
interdiction totale de l'avortement même
en cas d'inceste de viol ou de danger
pour la vie de la femme enceinte
certains États ont également fait
adopter des législations criminalisant
toute interruption de grossesse dès que
le pou du fétus est
détectable contrario d'autres États tels
que la Californie ont tenu à renforcer
ce droit plus récemment l'état de l'oho
a approuvé par référendum mardi 7
novembre 2023 l'inscription du droit à
l'avortement dans sa
constitution en Amérique latine 97 % des
femmes en âge de procréé vivent dans un
état dont la législation restreint
l'accès à l'avortement d'après la
Fédération internationale pour les
droits humains on l'a vu l'avancée
historique en décembre 2020 quand
constitué la dépénalisation de
l'avortement en Argentine est
aujourd'hui menacé avec l'élection du
nouveau président argentin dimanche
dernier l'Afrique est un des continents
où les lois sont les plus restrictives
en matière de droit à l'IVG et certains
États africains ont adopté des lois
criminalisant le recours à l'avortement
chaque année 6,2 millions d'avortements
à risque sont ainsi pratiqué en Afrique
subsaharienne causant au moins 15000
décès même en Europe ce droit reste
menacé et s'applique de façon très
hétérogène pour évoquer ensemble cette
disparité de législation dans le monde
je souhaite la bienvenue aux deux
participantes à cette première table
ronde madame Azal
ataille docteur en sciences politiques
chercheuse au laboratoire d'évaluation
interdisciplinair des politique publique
à scienp Paris et spécialiste de droit
comparés en matière d'accès à
l'avortement Madame Anne Légier docteur
en civilisation américaine maîtresse de
conférence à l'Université Paris Cité
spécialiste de l'histoire de
l'avortement et de la contraception aux
États-Unis donc je laisse sans plus
tarder la parole à Azal ataille
merci bonjour et merci pour cette in
production euh j'ai le plaisir de vous
adresser aujourd'hui pour faire un
panorama des lois et des politiques
publiques surous l'avortement dans le
monde qui est évidemment un vaste sujet
mais je vais quand même essayer de de
faire un de de le faire autour de
quelques grands thèmes que qui démandte
en fait la réglementation exceptionnelle
de l'avortement dans les lois et dans
les politiques publiques et des
conséquences problématiques qui en
découlent euh pour commencer j'aimerais
bien préciser pourquoi je parle des lois
et des politiques publiques en même
temps même s'ils sont pas vraiment conçu
par des mêmes groupes de personnes
ne traite pas forcément les mêmes sujets
mais en fait c'est qu'on sait du terrain
l'accès à la santé en général et des
l'accès à des soins de santé stigmatisés
comme l'avortement dépendent de
plusieurs facteurs qui peut relever du
droit et des lois mais aussi des
politiques publiques et de système de
santé on constate que même dans les pays
où l'avort légal il existe des problèmes
d'accès et les femmes continuent à se
heurter à des obstacles qui les
empêchent d'accè aider à l'avortement il
est donc importante de d'être consciente
que la loi seule ne garantit pas l'accès
à l'avortement et on doit penser à
l'avortement de manière holistique comme
un écosystème aux différentes dimensions
qui peut révéler des droits et des lois
mais aussi des politiques publiques et
système de santé et c'est important de
de d'être consciente aussi que ces
dimensions ne sont pas isolées non plus
mais contraire en fait à se croise assez
souvent par exemple on sait que la
criminalisation de l'avortement
contribue à la stigmatisation de
l'avortement de sorte que la manière
dont on parle de l'avortement dans nos
lois a un impact en fait sur le terrain
et sur l'accès à l'avortement je
voudrais développer sur la
criminalisation de l'avortement parce
qu'il monte assez de manière assez
simple et directe le traitement
exceptionnel de l'avortement dans la loi
et et en fait l'avortement constitue un
de rares soins de santé qui qui est
inclus dans les codes pénales à travers
le monde dans plusieurs pays et il est
souvent associé à des sanctions pénales
ainsi que sanctions administratives en
fait même dans les pays où l'avortement
est légal l'avortement reste toujours
inscrit dans le code pénal et c'est par
exemple le cas en Allemagne et en
Belgique entre autres et dans ce
contexte la légalisation de l'avortement
est en fait défini de manière
exceptionnelle à sa criminalisation et
on peut penser que c'est bon c'est pas
ça pose pas un problème parce que c'est
mieux que rien au moins il y a des
exceptions qui permettent pour permettre
à l'avortement mais quand même C
traitement de de l'avortement dans les
lois reste problématique parce que d'un
point de vue analytique et aussi
juridique parce que c lo confirme
toujours la criminalité générale de
l'avartement ceci est également en
contraduction avec les recommandations
de l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
qui recommande la dépanalisation
complète de l'abartement qui consiste et
je cite la dépénalisation consiste à
retirer l'avortement de la législation
pénale à ne pas appliquer d'autres
infractions pénales à l'avortement et à
s'assurer qu'il n'existe aucune sanction
pénale autour de l'avortement pour tous
les acteurs concernés aujourd'hui donc
la dépénalisation complète de
l'avartement est le cas seulement dans
un pay seul pays du monde et c'est le
cas de Canada où l'avortement a été
complètement décriminalisé il y a plus
de 30 ans ainsi la criminalisation de
l'avortement est problématique et
réflète le traitement exceptionnel de
l'avortement dans les lois à également
des conséquences sur l'accès à
l'avortement sur le terrain deuxème
thème ou mes connaissances si vous
voulez que j'aimerais bien aborder
concerne la légalisation de l'avortement
ou le droit à l'avortement donc tout
d'abord c'est important de dire qu'il ne
faut pas en fait confondre la
légalisation de l'avortement avec la
décriminalisation de l'avortement bien
qu'on parle de ces deux processus de
manière interchangeable en fait ça ça
constitue deux processus différentes euh
par exemple on a on a évoqué qu'il y a
récemment une verte de décriminalisation
de l'avortement en Amérique latine ce
qui constitue évidemment une une grande
évolution vu les restrictions précédente
mais si la dépénalisation de
l'avortement en Argentine a conduit à la
légalisation de l'avortement avec la
promulgation d'une loi spécifique qui
protège ce droit cela n'est pas encore
le cas au Mexique où l'avartement a été
décriminalisé et plusieurs exceptions
ont été définis dans les les codes
pénaux des États respectifs mais il
n'existe toujours pas une loi qui
protège et garantir l'accès à
l'avortement donc cela me mène à la
question de droit à l'avortement et que
je voudrais aborder qui nous concerne
ici au Sénat je pense surtout dans le
cadre de projet de loi sur la
constitutionnalisation de l'avortement
et c'est la question de savoir si
l'avortement est en droit et quand c'est
un droit et s'il y a des pays qui connu
en fait qui connaissent l'avortement
comme un droit donc malgré notre
tendance à faire référence au droit à
l'avortement quand on parle de
l'avortement euh dans les lois
l'avortement en fait est rarement
reconnu comme un droit en soi dans le
droit international on parle souvent de
principes des droits humaines à
respectecter autour de soin lié à
l'avortement mais on ne connaît pas
l'avortement pour l'instant et en soit
comme un droit pourtant quelques pays
dans le monde considèrent et traitent
l'avortement comme un droit et il s'agit
souvent des pays soit post-soviétiques
comme l'Arménie Azerbaïdjan Kazakistan
Turkménistan et la Russie ainsi que des
pays où l'avortement a été récemment
légalisé comme l'ARG Argentine et le
Népal et finalement aussi le Vietnam et
l'Islande donc en Arménie Kazakistan
Turkménistan et en Islande les lois font
référence soit au droit à l'interruption
de grossesse ou droit à l'interruption
artificielle de grossesse la loi au
Vietnam stipule que les femmes ont le
droit à l'avortement et au Népal la loi
affirme que les femmes ont le droit à
l'avortement sécurisé donc ce dernier
donc le cas de Népal en fait fait
référence à quelque chose bien attesté
dans la recherche sur l'avortement c'est
à savoir que là où l'avortement est
interdit l'interdiction de l'avortement
n'empêche pas les avortements de se
produire mais les rendre plutôt
dangereux et clandestin donc en fait ce
qui reste aux loi et aux politiqu
publiqu si vous voulez c'est de décider
si les avortements seront pratiqués de
manière sécurisé et non et c'est cette
langage qu'on observe dans les loi au
Népal donc la deuxième chose que je
voulais souligner est le fait que même
si l'avortement est rarement reconnu
comme un droit en soi il y a quelques
pays qui le font et on on peut aussi
faire ce choix en France ici donc mon
trème point consiste à aborder
l'avortement de manière holistique en
tant que écosystème comme j'ai sougéré
précédemment à la fois dans les lois
mais aussi au-delà peut-être des lois
dans les politiques publiques dans le
système de santé donc j'ai déjà
mentionné à plusieurs reprises et
c'était é aussi dans l'introduction que
l'accès à l'avortement en fait constitue
une dimension supplémentaire si vous
voulez à la légalisation de l'avortement
donc c'est pas la même chose et la
légalisation de l'avortement ne garantit
pas toujours la accès à l'avortement
mais c'est pas pour dire queon ne peut
pas faire des lois qui facilitent
l'accès à l'avortement là où cela est
nécessaire et dem monter donc un aspect
critique qui entre en jeu peut-être
quand on parle de l'accè à l'avortement
c'est le choix et c'est la question si
nos lois sous l'avortement don vraiment
le choix aux femmes cette question et
cette thème le choix est évidemment
central au sin de mouvement féministe et
qui revindiique le droit à l'avortement
et c'était l'une des raisons pour
lesquelle la criminalisation de
l'avortement a c'est problématisé parce
qu'elle ne don pas le choix aux femmes
si elles souhaitent continuer ou pas
leur grossesse et et si dans le pays où
l'avortement reste criminalisé ou ça ça
reste limité c'est l'État qui qui en
décide en fait mais aussi dans certains
pays où l'avortement est dépénalisé on n
toujours pas vraiment donné le choix aux
femmes mais aux médecin c'est une nuance
importante parce qu'on peut avoir des
situations où les demandes des femmes
sont en conflit avec CESU des médecins
et prendre le part de dans ce contexte
nous empêche de répondre à la demande
des femmes qui passent par cette
expérience d'une grossesse non désirée
et qui a besoin de l'avortement et c'est
le cas en Italie par exemple donc c'est
important que les lois et les politiques
publiques sous l'avortement se
concentrent sous les femmes et les
personnes ensentes qui vivent
l'expérience d'une grossesse non désirée
qui cherchent qui se font avorter et nos
système de sonin de santé doit être
centré sur les patients sous leurs
préférences et leurs besoins c'est aussi
important parce que nous sommes
confrontés souvent à une opposition qui
présente l'avortement comme un conflit
d'intérêt mais il faut reconnaître que
toutes les parties concernées n'ont pas
le même intérêt dans dans l'avortement
et ce sont celles qui ont besoin de
l'avortement qui doit être prioritaire
donc c'est pour dire que les lois et
politiques et les politiques publiques
sur l'avortement doivent être centré sur
les femmes et les homes decent leurs
besoins et leurs préférences alors pour
revenir à ma question et pour finir avec
ça comment peut-on faire des lois et des
politiques publiques qui facilitent
l'accès à l'avortement une formule pour
y parvenir comme je viens de le
mentionner peut-être se concentrer sur
les expériences les besoins et les
préférences des femmes et des personnes
ensentes une autre formule qui peut
alimenter nos réflexions et nos
politiques c'est de suivre la science et
les recommandations internationales
notamment cell de l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé et sur ce point je
dois noter que la France est en retard
par rapport à certaines recommandations
de l'OMS il existe encore nombreuses
restrictions arbitraires à l'avortement
dans nos lois et nos politiques
publiques le court délai pendant lequel
on autorise l'avortement et le délai
encore plus court pendant lequel on
autorise l'avortement médicamenteux ne
sont que quelques exemples qui sont pas
alignés avec les recommandations de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé
encore une formule ou plutôt une
question euh qui peut nous guider euh
dans nos réflexions et dans nos
politiques c'est la question de savoir
comment on peut garantir l'accès à
l'avortement même aux femmes et les
personnes les plus vulnérables et
marginalisées à celles qui ont des
ressources limitées celles qui sont
peut-être jeunes qui connaissent pas
forcément les lois et les politiques
publiques sur cette question merci de
m'avoir invité à l'occasion de cette
journée consacrée à l'accès à
l'avortement dans le monde j'y ai été
invité pour parler de la situation
actuelle aux États-Unis après le récent
revirement de jurisprudence rendu par la
Cour suprême en 2022 alors étant donné
le temps imparti je ferai un bref rappel
du cadre juridique dans lequel s'inscrit
l'arrêt d'obs versus Jackson Women's
Health Organization avant d'endresser
les conséquences les plus notables à
l'aide de quelques
exemples alors pour bien comprendre
comment se pose le problème aux
États-Unis il faut avoir à l'esprit que
la législation sur l'avortement dépend
des États fédérés et non de l'État
fédéral et le schéma classique de
nombreuses questions juridiques est
alors de savoir si telle loi d'un État
est conforme au principe constitutionnel
de la Fédération l'arrêt d'obs qui a mis
fin à 49 ans de protection
constitutionnelle du droit à
l'avortement a pour origine un procès
intenté dans le Mississippi et dont
l'objet était de déterminer si une loi
interdisant les interruptions de
grossesse avant le seuil de viabilité
était conforme à la Constitution et
l'affaire s'inscrivait dans une
stratégie relativement nouvelle de la
part des mouvements anti-avortement de
proposer des lois clairement contraires
à la jurisprudence en vigueur afin de
remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement alors en 2018 sous
l'impulsion des lobbyes anti-avortement
l'état du mississppi a avait adopté une
loi qui interdisait la plupart des
interruptions de grossesse dès la 15e
semaine d'aménoré ce qui était
anticonstitutionnel car contraire aux
arrêts RW versus W 273 et plan
Parenthood VKC de
1992 contre toute attente la Cour ne se
contenta pas de modifier le cadre
constitutionnel mais opta pour un
renversement total de jurisprudence un
fait qui est très rare aux
États-Unis où la continuité du droit est
un principe essentiel
mettant en avant une approche
originaliste de la Constitution la Cour
a statué que l'avortement ne pouvait
être un droit protégé donc le cadre
établi par r versus W qui n'autorisait
pas les États à interdire l'avortement
avant le seuil de viabilité et limiter
leur capacité à restreindre son accès
tout au long de la grossesse a donc
aujourd'hui totalement
disparu
alors la question de l'avortement a par
conséquent été renvoyé aux seuls États
fédérés qui sont maintenant libre de le
protéger de l'interdire et de le
réglementer à leur
guise alors dans les grandes lignes
quelle est la situation à l'échelle
nationale d'abord l'avortement est
désormais interdit dans 14 États l'avort
se état ont établi une limite
gestationnale gestationnelle pardon qui
va de 4 semaines de grossesse en
geéorgie ou en Caroline du Sud à 16
semaines euh de grossesse dans l'UTA
ensuite dans 5 état la situation est
actuellement incertaine en majorité
parce que des lois adoptées ont été
suspendues temporairement par un juge et
enfin euh en réaction à l'arrêt d'obs 20
États plus le district de Colombie
c'est-à-dire Washington DC ont établi de
nouvelles protections législatives ou
constitutionnelles pour le droit à
l'avortement alors pour avoir une
meilleure idée de la situation
actuelle je vous propose de regarder
deux cartes alors sur cette première
carte qui est extraite du du New York
Times on voit un panorama des lois
restrictives qui vont de l'interdiction
totale en rouge foncé jusqu'à des
limites
gestationnelles donc on a évoqué l'état
de luta Caroline du Sud et cetera alors
ce qu'on voit déjà sur cette première
carte mais qu'on verra encore mieux sur
la seconde c'est qu'on a de très grandes
dis
géographique avec les états protecteurs
donc le le code couleur est relativement
transparent donc les états protecteur
qui se situe en grande majorité sur les
deux côtes avec un un à quelques
exceptions près un grand désert médical
au centre et au sud du
pays donc on constate de très grandes
disparités
géographiques et je
voudrais vous parler un petit peu de de
certains états protecteur que qui qui se
situe donc comme on le voit sur la carte
essentiellement sur les les deux cô les
deux côtes mais comme on le voit
également sur la carte on a un état qui
est au centre hein l'état de l'Ilinois
où se trouve la ville de de Chicago que
vous
connaissez donc cet état occupe une
position centrale et son gouverneur a
professé la volonté d'en faire un état
refuge qui pourrait accueillir les
personnes provenant d'État voisin et
même d'État plus lointains euh dans cet
état les assurances privées et publiques
sont tenus de prendre en charge
l'avortement il n'y a pas de délai dit
de réflexion imposé il n'y a pas
d'obligation pour une mineure d'informer
ses parents et les infirmières
spécialiséses ou les médecins assistants
sont autorisés à pratiquer des avort des
avortements l'état protège également le
personnel médical les associations et
les patientes contre les poursuites
judiciaires qui seraient engagé dans un
autre pays ou un état ayant une
législation différente en revanche dans
cet état l'avorte n'est en principe pas
autorisé après le seuil de viabilité et
j'aimerais vous vous parler d'un autre
exemple l'exemple de l'État du Colorado
où la situation est un peu différente he
l'État du Colorado occupe aussi une
place centrale parce qu'il fait depuis
longtemps partie des États qui ne
disposent pas de limit gestationnell et
donc depuis de nombreuses années il
accueille des personnes en situation de
dépassement de délais qui proviennent de
tout le pays mais également de
l'étranger notamment de Fr
France alors parmi les États ayant
adopté des législations plus
restrictives je vais en évoquer deux le
Texas et la
geéorgie alors il faut savoir qu'en 2020
près de 60000 personnes ont ont avorté
dans l'État du Texas aujourd'hui
l'interdiction est totale ce qui laisse
peu d'alternative aux personnes
souhaitant interrompre une grossesse
voyager hors de l'État ce qui n'est pas
toujours possible notamment en raison du
coup ou bien la maternité forcée avec
les conséquences que l'on peut imaginer
au niveau psychologique social
économique mais aussi tout simplement
médical et là j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que lorsqu'on
parle de l'avortement aux États-Unis on
parle des interruptions de grossesse en
général et pas seulement des IVG
euh la loi au Texas est en effet
tellement restrictive qu'elle met en
danger la santé des personnes en âge de
procréer de manière globale euh les
médecins ne se sentent pas libres de
pratiquer certaines interventions qu'il
juge pourtant médicalement nécessairire
en cas de complications qui sont associé
à la grossesse plusieurs femmes dans cet
état ont récemment porté plainte en
disant que que la législation met leur
vie en danger en interdisant aux
médecins d'interrompre toute grossesse
même une grossesse qui ne serait pas
viable alors l'une d'entre elle à titre
d'exemple faisait une fausse couche et
elle n'a pas pu obtenir un curtage avant
de développer une septicémie hein donc
on voit les les les conséquences
drastiques et tout à l'heure on parlait
de grossesse non désirées mais ici il
s'agit de grossesses qui sont désirées
alors euh en geéorgie la situation est
un peu différente hein ça n'est pas une
interdiction totale mais l'avortement
est interdit desè 6 semaines d'aménorer
quand beaucoup de femmes ne savent pas
encore qu'elles sont enceintes de
surcroix l'état interdit l'utilisation
de fonds publics locaux exige que les
parents d'une mineur consentent à
l'intervention ou on reçiv notification
impose un délé dit de réflexion de 24 he
et ne permet pas aux professionnels de
santé qui ne sont pas médecins de
pratiquer un
avortement alors dans sa décision la
Cour avait affirmé le fait que le fait
de renvoyer le droit à l'avortement aux
États fédérés permettrait de résoudre un
certain nombre de questions qui qui
étaient resté en suspens dans les 50
dernières années en réalité il n'en est
rien la redobs a créé une situation
chaotique
complexe car elle soulève de nombreuses
questions de souveraineté alors des
questions de souveraineté entre État
fédéré et État fédéral entre États
fédérés eux-mêmes entre pouvoir exécutif
et pouvoir législatif entre loi tombé en
désuétudes et pratique courante et même
entre domaine d'application du droit
liberté d'expression liberté de
circulation et même liberté
d'entreprendre alors à titre d'exemple
on peut mentionner la question de
l'accès légale à l'avortement
médicamenteux qui nécessite comme vous
le savez sans doute d'avoir recours à
deux médicaments la MIF priston et le
misoprostol or plusieurs organisations
antiavortement ont intenté des actions
en justice pour contester la validité la
validité de la mise sur le marché en
2000 de la MIF priston par l'autorité du
médicament américaine la FDA et les
conséquences potentielles de cette
démarche sont nombreuses et difficile à
déterminer à l'heure actuelle euh alors
ce qui est beaucoup plus facile à
déterminer c'est le fait que l'accès à
l'avortement dont parlait ma collègue
euh a été grandement impacté par cette
cet arrêt de la Cour suprême alors tout
d'abord il faut quand même préciser que
les difficultés d'accès existait déjà
avant l'arrêt récent de la Cour suprême
l'arrêt de 92 KC avait considérablement
modifié le cadre constitutionnel en
accordant beaucoup plus de droit aux
États fédérés pour mettre en place des
restri qui s'appliquait aux patientes ou
euh au aux praticiens alors pour les
patientes je peux en citer un
l'obligation de faire une échographie
par exemple avant d'obtenir un
avortement ou des contraintes qui
s'appliquaient au praticiens beaucoup de
contraintes administratives surtout ces
dernières années des contraintes
administratives et matérielles qui ont
amené un assez grand nombre de cliniques
à devoir fermer car elle n'arrivait pas
à répondre à ces ces contraintes donc
l'accès à l'avortement était déjà
difficile avant l'arrêt d'ops dans de
nombreux États conservateurs néanmoins
les problématiques d'accès se sont
considérablement
euh aggravé après l'arr d'obs et touche
davantage les plus vulnérables celles
qui n'ont pas les moyens économiques
sociaux familiaux ou légaux de voyager
et je pense en particulier aux plus
démunis aux mères de famille isolé aux
mineurs aux personnes sans papier aux
femmes victimes de violence domestique
comme avant l'arrêt R vsus W dans les
États les plus restr
les personnes les plus affectées sont
celles qui n'ont pas les ressources
nécessaires pour contourner les
interdictions merci pour votre attention
et c'est avec plaisir que je répondrai à
vos
questions un grand merci pour cette
intervention Anne Légier sur la
situation aux États-Unis que je
qualifierai d'État désunis en matière
donc de protection pour la femme de de
l'avortement
euh merci à toutes les deux je vous
propose maintenant de de passer aux
questions si vous souhaitez si vous avez
des des des questions sur ces sujets
nous
avons c'est toujours dur de commencer
donc je vais poser la première question
euh on
parlait vous parliez du Mexique alors ça
c'est un lien les États-Unis et et le
Mexique pour le coup
parce que j'avais cru comprendre que au
Mexique le droit existait mais l'accès
était pas si simple que ça or j'ai aussi
entendu que bah au Texas si on voulait
se faire avorter le plus simple c'était
quand même de passer la frontière et
d'aller au Mexique donc ça pour moi les
deux informations j'ai l'impression
qu'ell se contredisent c'estd qu'il y a
accès alors peut-être qu'en fait la
vraie réponse c'est il y a un accès mais
quand on a les moyens de le faire quoi
les moyens financiers ou et là ça vous
concerne toutes les deux donc question
commune juste sur le Mexique ce que je
peux dire donc bon ça change en fait
parce que à Mexico City c'était déjà
légalisé donc il y a un accès et
beaucoup de femmes voyageaient vers le
Mexico City mais c'était pas forcément
le cas dans d'autres États
euh donc c'est ça qui a changé récemment
mais après avec la situation aux
États-Unis il y a pas mal des femmes qui
voyagent vers Mexique je pense que peut
leur répondre oui oui tout à fait euh
merci pour cette question madame la
Présidente donc il y a une longue
histoire en fait de voyage entre le
Mexique et les États-Unis avant W versus
Wade l'une des avocates qui a défendu
Jane RW dans dans l'affaire sarah
wdington a plus tard révélé dans sa
biographie qu'elle avait elle-même au
milieu des années 60 traverser la
frontière pour obtenir un avortement au
Mexique où c'était interdit à l'époque
et c'est justement ça permet de
souligner la différence entre
interdiction et pratique enfin la
différence entre loi et accès donc il y
a voilà euh actuellement effectivement
il y a un certain nombre de personnes
qui traversent la frontière pour obtenir
des soins d'ailleurs pas seulement
l'accès à l'avortement la contraception
mais aussi d'autres soins y compris
parfois
esthétique c'est quand même difficile
pour plusieurs raisons d'abord il faut
être en mesure de traverser la frontière
donc pour les personnes sans papier qui
sont nombreuses à la frontière ça ne
fonctionne pas et puis il y a des
questions de sécurité he récemment
quelques américains ont été kidnappés
certains tués donc ça n'est pas évident
mais en tout cas pour ce qui est de la
question de la la pilule abortive
beaucoup de de gens traversent la
frontière pour se rendre dans des
pharmacies au Mexique donc voilà la la
boucle
continue alors je donne la parole à Nick
billon puis ensuite Olivia Richard j'ai
vu d'autres mains se lever peut-être bon
déjà anque billon merci madame la
Présidente merci à vous mesdames chers
collègues pour cette présentation qui
nous fait rentrer tout de suite dans le
vif du sujet je voudrais d'abord dire
que je suis profondément attachée à ce
droit fondamental et que bien entendu
lorsqu'il y a eu des sujets au Sénat
portés dans l'hémicycle j'ai voté ces
propositions de loi avec enthousiasme et
conviction euh je voudrais peut-être
vous interroger par rapport à à au à la
contestation du droit de l'IVG qui qui
monte dans de nombreux pays est-ce que
vous pouvez dater préciser
finalement on voit un phénomène de masse
quand même depuis plusieurs années daté
cette montée de la contestation du droit
à l'IVG et je voudrais vous poser la
question aussi de savoir si il y a des
études qui montrent que plus les les les
les partis politiques extrémistes
montent plus ce droit à l'IVG est
contesté je voudrais aussi savoir si on
sait qu'on se dans cette délégation
madame la présidente qu'on travaille
pour la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes pour pour l'égalité la
parité est-ce que dans les pays où par
exemple l' l'égalité salariale n'est pas
un sujet donc est-ce que les pays où les
femmes ont plus facilement euh droit à
l'égalité est-ce que les femmes qui ont
plus facilement droit à l'égalité
salarial est-ce que ce droit est moins
mis en moins contesté euh et également
est-ce que les lorsque les femmes sont
plus nombreuses en politique poste à
responsabilité est-ce qu'il y a un lien
sur la contestation à la fois dans la
législation et puis une dernière
question je ne sais pas si vous pourrez
y répondre c'est sur les associations
lorsqu'il y a une contestation il y a
forcément des associations qui qui
portent cette contestation qui y
travaillent donc euh comment sont-elles
financées est-ce que euh comment table
table ronde suivante pardon alors vous
garderez vous pardon excusez-moi donc
moi j'ai j'ai j'ai groupisé toutes mes
questions parce que il y a l'audition du
ministre Marc F derrière et donc je
serais peut-être amené à vous quitter
donc du coup j'ai j'ai mis une question
à notre collègue Laurence Rossignol qui
animera la table ronde suivante merci à
vous
mesdames
alors ma collègue sera plus à même de
répondre de de manière globale hein
juste sur sur les États-Unis merci
beaucoup pour cette question
euh donc la la première partie qui était
sur les les partis extrémiste alors
évidemment l'exemple des États-Unis
c'est quand même assez marquant on voit
bien que la décision à l'arrêt BR versus
W c'est le résultat direct de l'élection
de de Donald Trump et de de ce le la un
peu de manipulation politique un peu de
chance qui lui a permis de nommer trois
juges extrêmement conservateurs à la
Cour suprême euh sur la question de de
l'égalité on peut aussi souligner qu'aux
États-Unis il n'y a pas de protection
constitutionnelle sur l'égalité et
que voilà le equal right amendment qui
est proposé très régulièrement depuis
des des
décennies et qui a priori ne semble pas
particulièrement controversé n'a pas pu
être adopté aux États-Unis donc sans
doute que le equ amendment pourrait
protéger et aurait pu permettre de de
contrer un peu les effets de de cette de
cet arrêt alors il y aurait encore
beaucoup de choses à dire mais je je te
laisse parler de du cadre international
h juste sur cette question bon en fait
le comptecout le backlash comme on
qualifie contre l'égalité de jein
l'égalité à femes hommes existait
toujours mais vous avez raison que il y
a une montée en fait on parle d'une
montée de ces mouvements et c'est qu'on
observe c'est surtout que tous ces
mouvements antichoix antigens sont très
bien connectés euh à à niveau national
mais aussi au niveau international ils
sont très présentes surtout dans les
dans les espaces de de l'ONU par exemple
et et ils travaillent pour leur agenda
mais ça existe toujours mais il y a une
monté et et si on regarde en fait
pourquoi on on obzarre cette cette
montée de de tout ce mouement et bien
sûr ça ça allient avec la politique là
où et l'avortement ça ça entre en jeu
parce que c'est h de droit qui est
attaqué aux premières en fait où il y a
tous ces mous an choix antigens
l'avortement et c'était le cas en
Pologne par exemple c'était vraiment le
droit qui en était attaqué au première
euh mais en fait juste aussi pour
répondre aux questions si on observe
moins de de de menaces contre euh à le
droit avartement dans les pays où il y a
plus d'égalité euh donc je vais répondre
ça à deux à à peut-être dans une manière
un peu inverse euh pour dire que il y a
plus euh donc où l'avortement est
légalisé on observe que la participation
des femmes au marché de travail augmente
donc on a on a pu observer cet effet un
peu dans le recherche et on on a pu
observer aussi où euh le l'égalité de
Gen l'égalité de femme homme est mise en
question il y a des attaques contre
l'avortement mais je pense que la table
rond prochaine va adresser plus plus en
détail à votre question Olivier
Richard je ne sais pas si j'arrive à
allumer le micro merci madame la
Présidente merci mesdames je je rejoins
an nique billon pour ses ses
remerciements sur cet événement qui
permet de de parler d'un sujet qui est
qui est à mon sens fondamental je suis
sénatrice des Français établis hors de
France et donc des Françaises établis
hors de France et l'Assemblée des
Français l'étranger qui réunit des élus
français du monde entier a pu travailler
sur ces questions et mettre en lumière
des disparités du du droit auxquel les
gens n'ont pas nécessairement accès et
connaissance c'est lorsque des
françaises arrivent dans un pays où
l'avortement n'est pas légal euh on se
rend compte qu'il y a toute une foule de
conséquences sur dont on éétait pas du
tout informé par exemple une femme qui
fait une fausse couche et qui se
retrouve interrogée par la police parce
qu'elle va à l'hôpital pour un suivi
médical classique donc c'est des
conséquences qu'on ne mesure pas et je
salue le travail de Laurence etal chapui
qui est présidente du conseil consulaire
à Dublin et qui a beaucoup travaillé sur
ces questions euh ma première question
madame madame at vous avez commencé
votre propos en disant que la loi seule
ne garantit pas l'accès à
l'avortement tout en faisant cette
distinction entre la légalisation et
l'absence de mesures pénales
sanctionnant finalement quel conséquen
pratique ça a à partir du moment où on
peut accéder à l'avortement même dans
des conditions peut-être de délis
insuffisants ou mais quelles
conséquences concrètes ça peut avoir et
quelle différence concrète voyez-vous
dans la reconnaissance d'un droit à
l'avortement ou d'une
liberté des femmes à accéder à cet
avortement et Madame Légier j'aurais
également une
question aux États-Unis a-t-on observé
justement un un une augmentation des
poursuites pénales des femmes dans les
États qui ont interdit cet avortement
est-ce que le système pénal s'est mis
également en œuvre outre les
impossibilités concrètes d'y accéder
merci
h du coup la criminalisation de
l'avortement a a certainement un impact
sur le terrain sur l'accès à
l'avortement euh par exemple on sait
bien que en fait les médecins veulent
bien sûr éviter souvent ils ont
peut-être peur de de de d'être d'être
criminalisé donc pour éviter ça et ils
vont faire peut-être une conception une
interruption beaucoup plus euh limité de
de la loi qui qui est en vigueur euh
donc là on on voit qu'il est pour éviter
la criminalisation il peut-être il
décide de ne pas pratiquer ou il il
interprète la loi d'une manière très
restrictive donc ça un impact on sait
très bien qui existe et c'était bien
attesté dans le recherche et puis aussi
le fait que en fait l'avortement est
dans le code pénal et c'est pas le cas
d'aut d'autres soins de santé ça quand
même contribue à la stigmatisation
générale de l'avortement donc ça reste
problématique en esprit mais aussi en
pratique si vous voulez euh donc je vais
prendre ça comme ça peut-être
oui merci beaucoup pour votre question
donc qui porortait sur les les
États-Unis alors sur la question de
l'augmentation des poursuites
judiciaires alors il y a il y a quelques
exemples mais qui sont relativement
marginaux et notamment il me semble dans
l'État de l'Indiana euh mais ce qui est
le plus marquant c'est c'est c'est la
peur qui a été
euh comment dire qui que déclenche cette
décision euh essentiellement
euh dans le corps médical c'est-à-dire
que quand qu'on a quand on a des
médecins qui hésitent à pratiquer des
soins qui sont pourtant des soins
élémentaire hein aider une femme qui
fait une fausse couche ou ou une
réduction riillonnaire en cas de de de
grossesse multiple et cetera ça a un
effet très très
important sur la qualité des soins une
autre chose c'est que le risque qui
plane même si en effet il est
relativement marginal le risque qui
plane fait que les femmes ont
sont sont plus hésitantes à se rendre
par exemple à l'hôpital quand elles font
une fausse couche hein donc on a un
impact qui est à la fois symbolique et
pratique je sais pas si si ça répond à
votre question merci et moi j'ai une
dernière question avant de passer à la à
la table ronde suivante à moins qu'il y
ait d'autres questions que je n'ai pas
vu j'ai une dernière question puisque
souvent on dit oui mais il faudrait
mieux développer la contr tion plutôt
que d'avoir recours à l'IVG est-ce que
les États qui interdisent l'IVG
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis n'essayent
pas aussi d'interdire la contraception
ah oui totalement totalement donc les il
y aurait beaucoup à dire sur les les
personnes qui sont manettees qui qui les
lobbyes anti avortement sont
généralement menés par des gens qui sont
sont hostile à la contraception et qui
sont parfois même hostiles à la
procréation médicalement assistée hein
puis que si par exemple dans l'État du
Kentucky on dit que dans la loi de
l'État du Kentucky on dit que la la la
vie commence à la conception donc ça
veut dire que ça peut remettre en cause
voilà les les questions de de d'accès à
la procréation médicalement assistée
donc clairement les gens qui sont
opposés à l'avortement aux États-Unis
sont également opposés euh à la
contraception voilà pour cette première
partie à suivre un deuxème débat sur la
question des blocages et l'accès
effectif à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse un débat animé cette fois par
la sénatrice du valde mararne Laurence
Rossignol bien on va poursuivre ce qui a
été engagé avec la première table ronde
et vous allez voir que les sujets qu'on
va aborder dans celle-ci euh sont
absolument dans la continuité de la
précédente et en particulier nous allons
nous intéresser à deux deux angles de
vue le premier qui est euh la question
de savoir euh comment euh se font les
obstacles à l'IVG euh y compris lorsque
les législations prétendent garantir le
droit à l'IVG comme et aussi la deuxème
le deuxème aspect de cette table ronde
c'est de nous intéresser à ces
adversaires de l'IVG qui sont-ils d'où
viennent-ils quels sont leurs réseaux et
surtout quels sont leurs financements
aussi et euh on va voir que on a affaire
à des mouvements qui sont organisés et
euh ont beaucoup de moyens avant juste
de passer la parole deux petites
remarques AINS identes qui me sont venu
à l'esprit en écoutant la table ronde
précédente la première c'est que quand
Anne Légier a évoqué Nic W Act ou Nic
amendment pour celles et ceux qui
voudraient en savoir plus en se
distraayant je recommande une formidable
série qui s'appelle muses America pour
cas vous ne l'auriez pas vu qui est
sur la meilleure plateforme française la
seule d'ailleurs une des meilleures
plateformes françaises voilà qui est sur
Canal maintenant s'est dit on enlèvera
pour le la
retransmission mais trop tard c'est je
sais trop tard c'est en direct mais bon
euh voilà et et qui raconte justement
l'histoire du mouvement féministe
américain au début des années 70 et la
bataille sur l'qual right Act vraiment
je vous la recommande je la recommande
aux collègues pour le leurs prochaines
vacances et la deuxième remarque que je
voulais faire c'est qu'en écoutant vous
partager quelque chose avec vous c'est
que j'ai été convaincu par des
obsériciennes des gynécologues qui ont
un long fait un long
travail sur l'accès à l'IVG pratique je
ne parle plus de grossesse non
désirée parce que la question du désir
est une question infiniment plus
complexe que celle de la volonté et je
pense que on peut avoir des grossesses
peut-être un peu désirées mais pas voulu
pas programmé pas choisi et je parle
plutôt maintenant de grossesse imprévue
ou de grossesse non vouu voilà c'était
cette petite remarque que je soumets à
la réflexion de de celles et ceux qui
nous écoutent et d'abord de vous-même et
donc on va évoquer de dans cet instant
les relais politiques et les moyens dont
il se doent pour faire contourner et
privé les femmes droit l'IVG nous avons
pour cela trois intervenants dans cette
deuxème table ronde que je vais vous
présenter Nil data directeur exécutif du
forum parlementaire européen pour les
droits sexuels et reproductifs qui est
un réseau de députés européens engagé
pour la promotion des droits sexuels et
reproductifs et qui nous dira peut-être
ce qu'il en est des Pays-Bas parce que
comme je passe pas mon temps à dire tous
les Programm de toutes les extrêmes
droites européennes dans le détail euh
je ne sais pas ce que cela raconte euh
sur l'accès à l'avortement ce voilà mais
donc je vous ajoute cette question là si
vous pouvez répondre euh Jean ees qui
est chargé de plaéidoyer pour l'Ong
International international iPass et
dont les travaux mettent en lumière
l'exportation des mouvement antichoix à
l'international au sein des sphères de
l'ONU et en Afrique tout
particulièrement puis Amandine clavau
qui est directrice d'études directrice
d'observatoire égalité femmes hommes de
la fondation jeanerè co-autrice d'un
excellent rapport intitulé droit des
femmes combattre le backlash qui a été
publié en février dernier dans un
partenariat entre l'ONG équipop et la
fondation jean-jorè et qui poursuivra
les sujets qu'on a que que j'ai indiqué
donc nild datata vous commencez cette
table
ronde merci beaucoup euh oui donc j'ai
une présentation qui est en train de
télécharger et donc pendant que ça se
fait j'aimerais tout d'abord remercier
Madame Rossignol et madame la Présidente
pour cette invitation euh comme on a
évoqué not mon organisation est une
organisation de parlementaires et c'est
pas je trouve particulièrement élégant
d'être ici au Sénat en France car il y a
23 ans c'est ici que notre organisation
a été fondée grâce en fait au sénateur
Lucian neirt et qui est bien connu dans
ce domaine et donc c'est vraiment un
réel plaisir d'être ici parmi vous
maintenant je vais aborder les questions
des mouvements anti antichoix antiggenre
et comment ils sont organisés je crois
que ça va répondre à certaines des
questions qui ont été évoquées lors de
la Table Ronde précédente donc je vais
regarder trois questions en particulier
qui sont-ils et comment ils sont
financés leurs idées leurs stratégies et
ensuite je vais terminer sur quelques
conclusions et je vais me je vais me
permettre d'aborder quelques sujets qui
ont été évoqués lors de de la discussion
précédente
ok donc qui sont-ils donc voici une
soupe de logo de différents mouvements
euh antigens qui sont actifs
principalement en Europe donc vous voyez
certains euh certaines organisations qui
sont présentes à l'échelle nationale
vous vous allez reconnaître la Fondation
Jérôme le jeune ici en France le
eclj le centre européen pour le droit et
la justice qui est basé à Strasbourg il
y a des organisations nationales dans
différents pays européens et des
organisations de la droite crétienne
américaine qui se sont
internationalisé ici en Europe et on va
revenir sur tout ça donc et aussi bon on
se rappelle tous de la manive pour tous
il y a 10
ans donc qui sont ces groupes d'abord il
faut euh il faut comprendre que ce sont
essentiellement en Europe des nouveaux
acteurs dans la société donc donc cette
nouvelle contestation et j'aborde une
question qui a été évoquée lors de la
discussion précédente cette nouvelle
cette contestation sur les droits l'IVG
d'autres questions de de progrès social
ne viennent pas du bas ce ne sont pas
issus de de de la société ces
contestations viennent de certaines
organisations bien précises et c'est
cette ce sont ces organisations qui sont
bien organisés qui ensuite mènent cette
contestation ok donc ça je crois qu'il
faut bien comprendre ce qui passe et
donc là ces nouveaux acteurs ce sont
essentiellement des ONG des Think Tank
des certains partis politiques
nouvellement créé
euh ils sont ils sont souvent
d'inspiration religieuse mais surtout
dans un contexte européen vont se
camoufler de cette inspiration
religieuse donc ils vont apparaître
comme étant laïque et ne vont pas mettre
en avant leur leur conviction religieus
mais vont mettre en avant éventuellement
d'autres d'autres apparences ils sont
pour la la liberté pensé pour la liberté
de religion et cetera pour le droit des
parents par exemple ok aussi une chose
c'est qu'ils sont euh ils occupent une
place intéressante sur les chiquier
politique ils sont proches de la droite
traditionnelle et aussi de de l'extrême
droite de la la droite alternative comme
on l'appelle dans certains pays et donc
ils peuvent fréquenter les deux milieu
assez aisément
ok aussi parmi les cibles h ok ça c'est
c'est le professeur Légier qui l'a
évoqué lors de la discussion précédente
on peut identifier cinq cibles
principales d'abord il y a tout ce qui
est à santé procréation reproduction ok
IVG contraception et cetera il y a
ensuite les droits sexuel il y a ensuite
les les les les droits LGBT ok donc le
mariage pour tous et cetera il y a
ensuite toutes les questions de genre ok
donc là il faut pas trop réfléchir à
qu'est-ce qu'on veut dire ou qu'est-ce
que eux pensent euh sont les les
questions de genre il suffit de mettre
la le mot genre quelque part pour
provoquer une une réaction
allergique aussi ou c'est pareil
ok euh un 4èe sujet sont les droits des
enfants ok ça c'est un sujet que souvent
dans une enceinte comme celle-ci on a
tendance à oublier mais le droit des
enfants surtout en particulier qui euh
qui a le dernier mot pour décider de du
bien-être de l'enfant est-ce la famille
traditionnelle patriarcale et cetera ou
bien est-ce que l'État aurait le droit
d'intervenir dans certains pays par
exemple les pays nordique il y a un
système d' assez interventionniste pour
protéger le droit de l'enfant qui est
reconnu comme ayant des droits à part
entière au-delà de celui de la famille
ah c'est parti euh ma présentation euh
et puis ensuite il y a aussi les
questions de de de liberté de religion
là l'argument c'est de c'est c'est
vraiment de dire que ma liberté de
religion est plus importante que sa
liberté que son droit d'accès à des à
des soins de santé ou d'autres personnes
de d'être protégé par contre des
discriminations si je peux prétendre que
c'est grâce à ma religion que je
pratique cette discrimination ok
d'habitude cette liberté de religion
s'applique essentiellement aux chrétiens
pas les autres religions OK et en
général on a constaté une laïcisation
une sécularisation du langage donc au
lieu de vieilles idées religieuses on on
le on on fait passer ces idées par une
une genre de lessive pour en faire
ressortir des des idées et un
vocabulaire qui ressemble à celui des
droits humains modernes
ok donc on a quelques grandes tendance
avec ces acteurs antiroit anti
antiggenre il y a d'abord une
professionnalisation donc là vous voyez
une carte de l'Europe avec où sont où
sont implantées certaines organisations
de la droite chrétienne américaine euh
et là vous voyez Londres Bruxelles
Strasbourg Genève Vienne et Rome ok ils
ne sont pas à Paris pas à Berlin pas à
Madrid ça c'est pas ils ont choisi ces
villes parce que ce sont les centres
d'institution internationales qui
abordent les questions des droits
humains OK et c'est pour ça qu' il y a
une concentration à Bruxelles et à
Strasbourg et à Genève donc et et avec
cette professionnalisation ils savent
comment fonctionnent les institutions
internationales ils savent ils savent
produire en projet de loi un amendement
et cetera ils ont des relais des alliés
politiques qui peuvent faire avancer
leurs propres idées deuxièmement il y a
une transnationalisation de ces
mouvements donc chacun de ces groupes
qui existent à l'échelle nationale donc
vous connaissez vos groupes en France il
y a des groupes semblables en Allemagne
en Suède aux Pays-Bas et cetera
maintenant ils ont ils se réunissent et
ils organisent des réunions où ils
partagent des bonnes idées des stratégie
et cetera nous connaissons plusieurs
types de ce de ce genre de réunion le
Congrès mondial des familles agenda
Europe et le réseau politique des
valeurs que Jeanne va nous expliquer
j'imagine un petit peu plus tard et puis
et pour ces questions de
transnationalisation j'ai amené un
rapport ici intitulé restaurer l'ordre
naturel qui explique comment ils se sont
organisés à partir de 2013 pour former
des stratégies et puis lancer des
initiatives dans une petite quinzaine de
pays donc concernant les financements
donc ça c'est quelque chose que que nous
n avons euh regardé donc nous avons
identifié tous les mouvements
antig-genre qui existent en Europe nous
on a pu en répertorié plus d'une C
vingtaine ok ensuite nous avons nous
avons fait simplement le travail de
recherche pour trouver leurs détails
financiers leurs comptes annuels et
cetera leurs bilan et nous l'avons
trouvé pour 54 d'entre de ces
organisations dans la région Europe donc
pour la décennie qui qui va de 2009 à
2018 sur ces 54 organisations des ONG
des fondations et cetera nous avons pu
identifier plus de 700 millions de
dollars euh qui allait dans ce mouvement
en Europe OK et donc si on regarde de
plus près ces 700 millions de dollars on
peut constater que au début de la
décennie ils étaient à moins de 20
millions de dollars par an à la fin de
la décennie en 2018 ils étaient à plus
de 80 millions de dollars par an donc si
votre budget augmente par un facteur de
4 vous pouvez faire bien plus de choses
on est en train de mettre à jour ces
données pour pour les sortir en amont
des élections européenne l'année
prochaine et je peux dire que même
maintenant les financements ont
davantage augmenté nous parlons plutôt
de 120 130 millions de dollars par an en
région Europe OK et donc et si on
regarde de plus près d'où vient cet
argent il y a trois zones géographiques
d'origine d'abord les États-Unis donc la
droite chrétienne- américaine
s'internation s'est internationalisée et
est présente ici en Europe avec des
bureaux permanents ce qui est
intéressant à retenir des des Américains
c'est qu'ils amènent le l'expérience
professionnelle américaine dans les dans
les sciences juridiques donc tout donc
ce sont des avocats qui établissent des
bureaux d'avocats ici en Europe et
ensuite cherchent des contentieux
juridiques pour les mener devant les
Cours ensuite il y a la Russie
essentiellement des oligarques qui
financent des mouvements d' extrême
droite des partis politiques d'extrême
droite je crois que vous en êtes
conscient ici en en France avec quels
seraient les acteurs qui pourraient
être concerné mais la plupart des
financements plus de 400 plus de 430
millions vient d'Europe même donc ce
sont nos riches qui financent ce
mouvement extrémiste en Europe ce
mouvement antidroit dans certains pays
il il bénéficie d'un soutien de l'État
par exemple la Hongrie la Pologne et et
et d'autres pays aussi
aussi donc je vais aborder maintenant
certains de leurs idées leurs stratégies
ok donc d'abord il y avait il y avait un
réseau intitulé agenda Europe qui était
bien organisé qui s'est qui organisait
des réunions annuel qui rassemblait plus
d'une centaine des mouvements antiggenre
antichoix à l'échelle européenne dans un
sommet annuel et ils avaient un un
manifeste commun intitulé restaurer
l'ordre naturel et donc qu'est-ce qu'ils
préconisent dans ce manifeste qui un
manifesteune C trentaine de pages
d'abord euh leurs croyances ne sont
leurs idées ne sont pas fondées sur des
croyances religieuses mais sur la loi
naturelle ok donc là un exemple de
laïcisation de leur langage mais si on
si on connaît bien ce ces acteurs loi
naturelle fait référence à certains
principes catholiques et donc c'est un
genre de code pour renvoyer euh à
certaines idées religieuses tout en
passant pour laïque à un public plus
large ok catholique ou chrétien parce
que les mouvements évangéliques sont
aussi très présents l'origine de la
plupart l'origine intellectuelle de ces
idées est essentiellement catholique et
puis ensuite a été adopté par d'autres
confession chrétiennes
OK et là on peut voir que leur façon
d'organiser leur pensée n'est pas d'être
contre certaines idées ils ne sont pas
contre l'IVG ils sont pas contre les
droits sexuels et cetera mais ils sont
pour des certaines idées ils sont pour
la vie pour la vie dès le moment de la
conception jusqu'à la mort naturelle et
donc là vous voyez IVG euthanasie droit
de mourir en dignité font partie de la
même chose famille famille
traditionnelle patriarcale
hétérosexuelle et pour la liberté la
liberté religieuse essentiellement ma
liberté religieuse est plus importante
que vos droits et puis vos
protection et là si on regarde à un pe
par pardon ok donc je vais je vais
terminer ok oui ok vous reviendrez après
ok donc je en fait je vais je vais
sauter certaines
certaines slides et puis un des réseaux
importants un des réseaux importants
c'est c'est le réseau politique des
valeurs qui s'est réuni à
Bruxelles en 2017 et puis avait son
propre plan d'action et donc là c'est un
c'est un extrait de ce plan d'action et
là vous pouvez voir sur les questions
d'IVG ils ont une stratégie la stratégie
c'est celle de
prévention restriction et interdiction
et donc pour prévention ça ne veut pas
dire promouvoir l'accès à la
contraception et cetera c'est vraiment
créer des obstacles à tout ce qui est la
femme et son accès à
l'IVG reconnu selon le droit légal là
j'ai je crois que j'ai abusé de mon
temps donc je vais terminer sur ceci
merci vous n'avez pas abusé de votre
temps mais comme il faut le partager ce
temps et puis que vous êtes un peu tous
les trois
sur des travaux identiques je propose
que la parole va être maintenant à
l'intervenante suivante et j'ai oublié
votre prénom mais il va me revenir tout
de suite Jean Jean voilà le nom de
famille avec Jean éèz et puis CAV et
puis vous reprendrez la parole après les
trois interventions pour compléter ce
qui n'aura pas été dit par vos amis
d'accord Jean c'est à vous merci
beaucoup bonjour à tous et bonjour à
toutes
donc pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
iPass nous sommes une organisation
internationale donc l'unique mission est
vraiment d'élargir l'accès à
l'avortement ça passe par le
renforcement des systèmes de santé
l'accompagnant de gouvernement la
création de stratégies politiques qui
visent vraiment à la dépénalisation on a
des bureaux dans une vingtaine de pays à
travers le monde surtout l'avortement
est fortement criminalisé donc comme EPF
ça fait plus de 15 ans que nous traquons
le mouvement antigre cette recherche
vise à démasquer et à bien sûr
désenclaver les offensives de ces
acteurs avec nos partenaires de terrain
les médias la société civile le monde
médical et le monde féministe il est
impossible pour nous de sécuriser nos
acquis aujourd'hui sans vraiment
comprendre nos détracteurs et c'est donc
ça dont je vais parler aujourd'hui donc
comme l'a bien dit Nil ces acteurs et
surtout ce dont nous parlons ce matin
ils sont spécifiquement engagés contre
l'idéologie de genre et ils utilisent
l'opposition à ce qu'on appelle les dssr
donc les droits à la santé sexuelle et
reproductive et les droits LGBT comme un
principe d'organisation pour attirer des
fonds et de l'influence politique à des
fins discriminatoires et des fins
antidémocratiques aujourd'hui nous
considérons que les défis qui sont posés
aux espaces nationaux régionaux et
internationaux sont sans précédent et
qu'on assiste à une grande à une
destruction en grande partie des acquis
de nos droits humains du siècle dernier
alors pour dans la continuité de ce dont
n vient de parler qu'est-ce que la GPA
donc la gestation pour autrui l'accord
de commerce de Cotonou de l'Union
européenne la peine de mort qui
criminalise l'homosexualé en ouanda et
le droit à l'avortement peuvent avoir en
commun et bien ces thématiques qui
pourrait sembler très distinctes ont
tout été vivement abordé la semaine
dernière au siège de l'ONU lors d'un
rassemblement antidroit de la plus haute
envergure à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme le 5e sommet
transatlantique organisé sous le thème
unir les cultures pour la vie la famille
et les libertés était organisé par le
réseau politique pour les valeurs celui
dont il vient de parler le pnfv et ses
alliés donc le pnfv est une plateforme
de origine ibérique et c'est une des
plateformes les Ultra conservatrices les
plus puissantes du monde elle tente
d'influencer des politiques
internationales en travaillant de très
près avec des Think Tank ultra
conservateurs des ONG fondamentalistes
et d'extrême droite américaine ainsi que
des fondations privées chrétiennes et
des pays comme la Hongrie je signale
aussi que Cataline Novac en était la
présidente jusqu'à il y a quelques
années donc ça fait plus de 10 ans que
le pnfv se consacre à renverser le
système des nations- Unies et à éroder
le droit de population historiquement
marginalisée donc la semaine dernière on
a vu plus de 200 dirigeants politiques
et civies de 40 pays à New York le
ministre de la Protection de l'Enfance
de l'équateur la ministre des femmes du
Nigéria des députés du Paraguay de la
Finlande du Panama de la Colombie du
Brésil des membres du Parlement européen
Sam George un député du Ghana qui a été
instrumental dans la loi visant à
criminaliser les droits LGBT au Ghana
ainsi que Luce aquelo une députée de
l'Ouganda qui a aussi joué un rôle
central dans la légalis dans la dans la
loi pénalisant l'homosex ualité en
Ouganda le député de l'Argentine et
c'est à propos il a dit il n'est pas
possible qu'aujourd'hui l'endroit le
plus dangereux au monde soit l'utérus là
où la vie humaine est la plus menacée
cette réunion donc de partage de bonnes
pratiques et du renforcement des
synergies intervient un moment de grande
anxiété mondiale en particulier face aux
efforts visant à affaiblir les espaces
multilatéraux comme l'ONU et par ce même
biais les droits des femmes elle montre
à quel point le mouvement antidroit a
pénétré des hautes sphères du pouvoir et
comme il est align autour de certaines
thématiques opportunistes pour un agenda
mondial commun qui va au-delà de de
l'Europe donc ce qu'on constate ces
dernières années comme l' dit Nil c'est
une une question d'échelle des
offensives une rapidité une
sophistication de leur stratégie avec
une augmentation de ces réseaux qui sont
originaires d'Europe et des États-Unis
donc je vais parler ici de quelques
stratégies sans trop aller dans le
détail vous l'avez bien compris on voit
le ciblage du genre et de la diversité
de genre à l'ONU et dans les espaces
diplomatiques régionaux donc depuis
quelques temps fait face à une paralysie
normative pendant les négociations voire
parfois des régressions en tout cas un
ralentissement pour toutes les
négociations qui ont à voir avec les
dssr le genre et qui sont censé les
promouvoir notamment pendant la
commission annuelle sur le statut de la
femme donc l'opposition attaque
directement le système de l'ONU elle
prône le retrait des accords le le le
définancement pardon et la
délégitimation de ses agences elle
discrédite les mécanismes tout en en
abusant d'une stratégie d'entrrisme donc
en formant des
diplomates à participer à ces réseaux en
créant des ONG et des système parallèle
de droits humains qui n'ont aucune
légitimité légale comme le consensus de
Genève donc ils utilisent les cours
régionales comme l'a dit Nil des droits
humains pour une mise en réseau
transnational permanente avec une une
approche qui est beaucoup plus
technocratique qu'avant avec une
orientation constitutionnelle qui
s'inspire beaucoup de groupes juridiques
américain et qui investissent du coup
dans le renforcement de capacité à
l'international en litige stratégique
anti-avortement donc on voit des groupes
par exemple autrichiens qui mettent sur
place des
réseaux de litigateurs en ouganta par
exemple Provis il a c'est pas juste au
niveau des nations- Unies on le voit
aussi au niveau de la Cour
interaméricaine qui est menacée depuis
2013 de cout budgétaire du parti
républicain américain qui l'accuse de de
violer la souveraineté nationale au nom
du droit à l'avortement et des droits
LGBT dans les Amériques on entend ces
mêmes arguments à l'Union africaine et
contre la Commission européenne le le
groupe iclj dont dont n parlait à
l'instant a publié son deuxè rapport
l'année dernière qui met en lumière la
soi-disant collusion entre
l'organisation open Society Foundation
de George Soros et les cours euh de la
Commission européenne on les retrouve
aussi là on les attend un petit peu
moins donc à l'Organisation mondiale de
la santé certes mais aussi par exemple
avec l'accord de Cotonou donc c'est un
accord économique entre les États
d'Afrique des Caraïbes et de l'Union
européenne qui repose sur trois piliers
de coopération développement économique
et commercial a priori cet accord
n'avait pas connu de controversse depuis
ces 20 ans d'existence mais des
dispositions récentes qui ont été
introduites sur le genre et sur la santé
en ont fait un cheval de troit de
l'opposition là on a vu un think tank
neerlandaméricain donc le Christian
Council international le politic network
for values dont je parlais une une
organisation américaine family watch
international lancer une croisade sans
précédent contre l'accord commercial
européen avec un un lobbying intense au
près de gouvernement africain et
caribéens ils ont donc dévié le langage
démonisé la nature de l'accord
provoquant au niveau national en Habibi
au Nigéria des conférences de presse des
mobilisations des pétitions et ils ont
fait un excellent travail et quand je
dis excellent c'est parce que ça a
suscité l'indignation de certains gouver
gouvernement qui ont menacé de son
retrait il y a des gouvernements qui se
sont euh qui se sont retirés euh de
l'accord et ça a surtout ralenti euh les
négociations suite à l'adoption du
projet de loi qui a cri criminalisé
l'homosexualité par le Parlement
ougandais en avril 2023 ces mêmes
groupes donc les groupes transnationaux
dont j'étais en train de parler ont
organisé une conférence
interparlementaire régionale où ils ont
décrit l'accord commercial comme une
menace existentielle pour les familles
et les enfants africains à la tête de
ces accusations on trouve les dirigeants
européens du Christian counc
international et de Family watch
international qui ont été félicité par
la première dame de l'ouanda Janette
moussevini donc je vous laisse apprécier
un petit peu l'ironie de de ces rapports
pour rappel bien sûr la loi qui vient
d'être passée en Ouganda est le fruit de
long années de travail de groupes qui
sont aussi internationaux que nationaux
bien sûr donc ces groupes dont on est en
train de parler aujourd'hui comme family
watch international et leur partenaires
parlementaires font tout pour affaiblir
les lois et les normes internationales
qui protègent l'égalité de genre
l'avortement et le droit des minorités
en Afrique ils sont également très
mobilisés contre l'éducation complète à
la sexualité les directives de l'UNESCO
en mobilisant comme l'a dit Nil la
panique morale les droits parentaux en
citant un complot féministe
international promouvant l'homosexualité
et la masturbation des enfants et donc
des États-Unis au Panama au Sénégal on
trouve une grande collusion en entre ces
groupes ultra conservateurs et des
écoles au niveau local et vous
connaissez ce problème également en
France donc ça peut ressembler à des
censures des mouvements sentiers
pornographie pour l'éducation à la
maison et cetera on le voit aussi comme
on le dit depuis ce matin
l'instrumentalisation du pouvoir
judiciaire donc on l'a vu l'année
dernière avec la chute de rovy Wade et
comme pendant les la période du Global
gag donc la règle de Mexico City qui
censure et qui couple les financements
des organisations internationales et des
structures médicales qui offrent les
services d'avortement qui est mis en
place pendant euh des administrations
républicaines en tout cas qu'il a été
fait depuis depuis les 20 dernières
années on voit que l' ROV Wade a déjà eu
des impacts négatifs sur des processus
législatifs à l'international donc au
Kenya et au Nigeria il y a déjà eu des
motion euh d'arrêter de processus
législative progressif qui était en
faveur de des dssr où l'arr rovy Wade a
été cité on le voit également en
Éthiopie il y a eu un effet électrifiant
en fait pour le mouvement
anti-avortement euh en Afrique mais on
l'a aussi vu en Inde où il a été cité
aussi par des mouvements euh
anti-avortement et donc ces groupes
travaille en partenariat ou pour les
organisations dont Nil et moi on ét en
train de parler parce qu'une des
dynamiques qu'on voit depuis ces
dernières années c'est une une
localisation en fait du staff de ces
organisations américaines et européennes
qui vont engager un leadership africain
ouvrir des bureaux euh à l'Union
africaine et et engager en fait des
visages locaux euh pour euh pour leur
plaidoyer euh donc ces groupes
deviennent plus créatifs plus efficaces
il s'inspirent aussi nous de notre
activisme et gagne en visibilité un
groupe qui était sur sur les logos de la
la soupe de Nil et donc citizen Go qui a
un groupe ultra conservateur d'origine
espagnole euh de mobilisation digitale
ce groupe a été instrumental dans la
fermeture de soins de santé de la
reproduction au Kenya euh sous prétexte
qu'ils offrai des soins des soins
avortement illégaux et ce qu'on constate
aussi c'est euh une prolifération du du
militantisme antiavortement à
l'américaines euh donc on va le voir
avec des vigiles devant des cliniques
par
exemple des marches pour la vie au
Nigéria et quelque chose qui est encore
assez discret pour l'instant en Afrique
mais qui ne serait tardé à à à être
amplifié c'est la stratégie des centres
euh de crise de de grossesse en crise
une stratégie qui est très utilisé en
Europe et aux États-Unis qui consiste à
offrir des soins de santé gratuits aux
femmes pauvres en leur en bien sûr les
incitants à ne pas avorter essayer de
les convaincre de garder leur grossesse
ça peut aussi passer par des formations
du corps médical en objection de
conscience ça c'est une nouvelle
stratégie que l'on voit et donc se
concentrer sur les assistantes sociales
les infirmières pour les
inciter à objecter ce qui est quand même
particulièrement pernicieux voilà donc
vous l'avez compris tout ceci a un
impact direct sur la vie des femmes sur
leurs choix reproductifs sur les
personnes LGBT et sur leur famille et ça
enflamme vraiment les hostilités au
niveau communautaire au niveau national
même si l'opposition n pas forcément
nouvelle ou importée l'extrémiste et le
populistme viennent aggraver ces
initiatives et se lie à d'autres
tendances mondiales antiféministes et
nationalistes et le genre devient le
véhicule de politique antidémocratique
et permet une normalisation de ces
discours extrémistes avec des
passerelles soi-disant inoffensives
comme le droit euh des parents voilà
donc pour conclure je dirais qu'il est
temps de réfléchir à des réponses
collectives et d'entériner nos soutiens
aux actions ETX organisations de terrain
de recherche au renforcement des
institutions démocratiques et à la
survie et au maintien des espaces
multilatéraux il faut forger un
consensus politique auprès de nos
insenses sur la valeur fondamentale et
inaliégable de ces droits et de leur
interdépendance dont l'accès à
l'avortement et la santé sexuelle et
reproductive et bien sûr une pierre
angulaire je vous
remercie merci Jeanne euh merci Amandine
maintenant c'est à
vous bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
tout d'abord à à la délégation au droits
des femmes et à l'égalité des chances du
Sénat pour cette invitation dire un mot
rapide sur la Fondation Jean jores pour
celles et ceux qui ne nous connaîtraient
pas nous sommes une fondation politique
reconnue d'utilité publique et à ce
titre là on travail sur l'ensemble des
des politiques publiques dont les
questions égalité femmes hommes font
parti et sur lesquelles nous sommes
particulièrement engagés notamment en
matière de défense des droits et santé
sexuelle et reproductif et donc pour
cette intervention je vais m'appuyer sur
le rapport que nous avons produit donc
qui est ici droit des femmes troit des
femmes combattre le backlash avec éipop
et également sur l'essai que j'ai écrit
droit des femmes le grand recul qui
traite euh notamment de l'impact de la
crise sanitaire sur les dro droit des
femmes en Europe donc on l'a vu dans la
première table ronde he concernant le
droit à l'avortement que celui-ci est
protégé par des textes internationaux
mais qu'en dépit de de tout ça il y a un
certain nombre d'obstacles qui sont
structurels politiques
législatifs il y a une hétérogénité de
ces cadres législatif qui existe et donc
on l'a vu l'avortement est autorisé dans
seulement 77 pays euh il est
complètement interdit dans 22 pays ça a
pour conséquence que en fait que près
d'une femme sur deux d'après un rapport
du FNUAP euh ne dispose pas librement de
son corps dans le monde euh autrees
conséquen près d'une IVG sur de est donc
réalisé dans des conditions euh non
sécurisées pour les femmes d'après le
goutmarer Institute parce qu'on le sait
euh une femme qui ne souhaite pas
poursuivre une grossesse mettra tout en
œuvre pour cela en dépit euh des
dispositifs législatifs qui les
interdiraient
si on se penche sur le l'accès à
l'avortement dans l'Union européenne il
est autorisé dans 25 États membres sur
sur 27 Malte et la Pologne l'interdisent
quasiment
totalement il faut aussi rappeler que
Andor et le Vatican l'interdisent aussi
et je vais m'arrêter sur plusieurs
exemples au niveau
européen notamment notamment en terme de
stratégie la traduction politique que
ces mouvements antidroits arrivent à
mettre en œuvre lorsqu'ils sont au
pouvoir et donc un principalement qu'on
retrouve au sein de parties d'extrême
droite et de la droite populiste et donc
le cas de de la Pologne qui est assez
emblématique il est aujourd'hui
quasiment impossible d'avorter en
Pologne sauf en cas de danger pour la
vie de la femme de viol ou d'inceste
cette législation elle est en place
depuis janvier 2021 elle est issue d'une
longue bataille qui a été mené par le
Parti conservateur droit et justice
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir en en 2015
et qui n'a donc pas cessé de vouloir
interdire cet accès des des femmes à à
l'IVG ils ont d'ailleurs profité de la
crise sanitaire pour essayer de passer
ce projet de de loi parce que les
confinements permettaient pas la
mobilisation des des populations et ils
ont voulu faire en sorte que les IVG
soient considérés comme comme non
essentiel ce projet loi n'est pas passé
à ce moment-là mais il a abouti donc en
en janvier 2021 on estime qu'il y a
environ 200000 avortement euh clandestin
pardon qui ont été réalisés par an
depuis la mise en place de de cette
législation en janvier 2021 le collectif
avortement sans frontières a réalisé euh
a aidé pardon 33000 femmes à avorter
entre janvier 2021 et janvier
2022 et surtout la la première des
conséquences c'est qu'on déplore la mort
de plusieurs femmes polonaises parce que
les médecins ont refusé d'intervenir par
peur de poursuite judiciaire parce qu'il
risqueent 3 ans de de prison et donc en
fait c'est la santé des femmes et en
réalité leur vie qui est clairement mis
en danger autre élément de de
criminalisation des femmes les médecins
sont obligés de notifier dans un
registre les femmes enceintes depuis la
mise en place d'un arrêté ministériel en
juin 2022 autre autre élément les
militantes féministes sont
particulièrement menacé j'en veux pour
preuve Martha Lampart qui est
cofondatrice du mouvement la greffe des
femmes est actuellement menacée de mort
elle est placée sous protection
judiciaire ou encore le cas de justina
vridrinska qui est une militante
féministe qui a été reconnu coupable par
la justice d'avoir prêté assistance à
l'IVG à la pratique d'une IVG et
condamné à 8 mois de travaux d'intérêt
général et enfin dernier élément
dernière trouvaille dans la
criminalisation des femmes polonaises un
laboratoire polonais à la demande du
gouvernement conservateur a mis au point
un test qui permettrait de savoir si une
femme a eu recours ou non à une IVG
médicamenteuse et donc là je vais
m'arrêter sur les élections législatives
qui ont eu lieu qui ont vu la victoire
du bloc libéral et de centregauche et
qui là en fait montre un marque un vrai
tournant parce qu'on l'a vu l'avortement
a été en fait un élément de mobilisation
de la part des jeunes et notamment des
jeunes où leur participation a été
beaucoup plus importante qu'au scruin
précédent et une mobilisation également
de la part des femmes à noter l'opinion
publique polonaise est en fait très
largement favorable à la à l'avortement
à près de 84 % donc on voit bien en fait
un yatus entre ce gouvernement
conservateur et l'opinion publique c'est
exactement la même chose d'ailleurs
qu'on retrouve aux États-Unis où
l'avortement est très largement partagé
par la population et donc là il va
falloir suivre ça avec particulièrement
d'attention pour voir si don NAT tulsk
qui qui pardon et le leader de
l'opposition a promis de libéraliser
l'avortement arrivera à faire passer ces
ces proposition de loi la gauche a déjà
déposé deux propositions de loi mais en
fait la la réalité pour la promulgation
de de ces lois il faut la signature du
président Doua et ce président est
proche du parti Droit et Justice donc il
y a une vraie bataille qui va qui va
s'enclencher et qui va falloir suivre
avec
attention l'autre exemple que je voulais
évoqué c'est le cas de la Hongrie et
donc dans cet exemple là c'est assez
intéressant parce que là la Pologne on
parlait d'un cadre législatif qui était
contraignant en Hongrie le l'avortement
est autorisé jusqu'à 12 12 semaines et
pourtant dans les faits il est de plus
en plus difficile d'y accéder le
gouvernement de Victor de Victor Orban
qui est donc un un conservateur n'a
cessé de multiplier ses atteintes et
aujourd'hui le gouvernement a oblige les
femmes qui souhaitent avorter à écouter
les battements du cœur du fetus pour les
dissuader d'avorter à noter que le chef
de de ce gouvernement là a été l'ôte
d'un sommet sur la démographie où on
trouvait tous les acteurs que nel et
Jeann ont ont cité tous ces acteurs donc
antidroit parce que nous dans notre
rapport on parle de mouvement antidroit
ces acteursl ils s'attaquent comme on
l'a dit au droits des femmes au droits
des personnes LGBT aux droits des
personnes migrantes donc c'est
l'ensemble des droits humains qu'ils
attaquent et donc pour eux le finalement
la bataille contre le droit à
l'avortement ça va de paire avec une
politique nataliste et donc pour eux ils
considèrent que les femmes doivent faire
davantage sage d'enfant et Victor Orban
a trouvé une allié de choix puisque la
présidente kathaline Novak était
présente à un sommet international LA
Woman
deliver qui était qui se tenait donc à
Kigali en en juillet dernier et elle est
intervenue pour parler de leur politique
en matière d'égalité femmehomme en en
disant que leur politique et leur
objectif principal c'était
l'augmentation de la fécondité et elle
déclar et même qu'elle espérait que sa
fille ait 10 enfants si elle le
souhaitait euh on va passer maintenant
de de l'autre côté des Alpes et
j'aimerais parler maintenant du cas de
l'Italie euh où là aussi la l'avortement
est autorisé jusqu'à jusqu'à 12 semaines
depuis la loi de
1978 mais on le sait cet avortement il
est très difficile d'accès en raison de
la clause de conscience qui est invoqué
par près de 70 à 90 % des médecins dans
certaines régions et ça ce sont des
chiffres
du ministère de la Santé en Italie de
2021 et depuis l'arrivée de Georgia
melony qui est donc cette leader leader
du parti d'extrême droite fratellit
d'Italia et bien les craintes sont
réelles par rapport à la remise en cause
du droit à l'avortement elle a fait
campagne sur plusieurs slogans et dont
notamment l'un est de du droit de ne pas
avorter elle souhaite mettre en place un
fond pour supprimer les causes
économiques et sociales qui auraient
conduit
les femmes à à
l'avortement si on regarde également son
son gouvernement elle a nommé une
ministre de la Famille et l'intitulé
aussi de ce portefeuille est intéressant
ministre de la Famille de la natalité de
l'égalité des chances Eugenia rochella
qui est connu pour ses positions
anti-avortement anti mariage pour tous
dès son arrivé au pouvoir il y a
également eu une proposition de loi qui
a été portée par un sénateur Mauricio
Gaspari qui fait partie du parti Forza
Italia donc de l'équivalent de de la
droite et donc il a proposé de modifier
l'article 1 du Code civil pour faire en
sorte de remettre en cause le droit à
l'avortement et notamment en faisant
reconnaître le fetus comme une
personnalité juridique c'est exactement
là aussi un combat que l'on retrouve
actuellement euh aux États-Unis et enfin
on voyait déjà quand l'extrême droite
était au pouvoir à la tête de certaines
régions en Italie qu'il souhaitent
remettre en cause ce ce droit à
l'avortement ou en tout cas contourner
les dispositifs législatifs il y a trois
exemples notamment dans le Piémont où
ils ont mis en place des aides
financières pour convaincre les femmes à
ne pas avorter ils ont financé
massivement là aussi des associations
antichoix
ou encore dans les dans les marches donc
cette région où en fait ils ont tout
simplement refusé d'appliquer une
directive nationale qui permet l'accès à
une IVG
médicamenteuse troisième exemple il y a
une proposition dans dans les abruses
pour mettre en place des sépultures pour
fetus avorté c'est une proposition qui a
été soumise plusieurs fois qui n'est pas
passée mais là en fait on voit bien en
fait les tentatives les tentatives
répétées et puis autre exemple Georgia
Meloni elle s'attaque aussi au droits
des personnes LGBTI plus et à leur droit
et santé sexuelle et reproductif elle a
déclaré oui à la famille naturelle non
au lobby LGBT et de fait elle souhaite
effacer des actes de naissance le nom de
la mère non biologique pour les femmes
pour les couples de femmes qui qui
auraient eu pardon recours à la à la PMA
donc on voit bien là les multiples
atteintes et les différents fronts qui
sont qui sont attaqués et les réelles
craintes que l'on peut voir peser pour
les femmes italiennes et enfin dernier
exemple j'aimerais évoquer le cas de la
Suède parce que c'est un pays qui est
très souvent cité et à juste titre pour
pour sa politique en matière d'égalité
figure dans l'ensemble des des des des
comment dire des classements au niveau
internationaux mais pourtant les menaces
elles sont quand même là parce que en
dépit du fait que l'avortement est
autorisé depuis 18 semaines il faut
rappeler que la jusqu'à jusqu'à jusqu'à
18 semaines pardon euh jusqu'à 18
semaines il faut rappeler que l'arrivée
au pouvoir de la coalition de la droite
et de l'extrême droite pourrait pourrait
nuire et fragiliser ce droit je vais
m'intéresser là au cas notamment de la
vice-présidente du Parlement qui
s'appelle Julia cronling et qui est loin
d'être anodine donc elle est
vice-présidente du Parlement elle est
très connue pour ses positions
anti-avortement elle a déposé pas moins
de 54 motions en l'espace de 12 ans pour
restreindre le droit à l'avortement en
en Suède en attaquant différents biaiss
que ce soit le délai de recours que ce
soit la question de la limitation pour
les IVG tardive ou encore l'introduction
pour une clause de conscience qui
pourtant n'existe pas dans la loi
suédoise autre autre exemple également
le gouvernement suédois a annoncé dès
son élection qu'il souhaitait abandonner
la diplomatie féministe or la Suède
était pourtant l'un des pays pionniers à
l'avoir misise en place en 2014 donc on
voit bien là encore les différentes
attaques qui qui font qui font auxqueles
les femmes en Europe font
face et donc par conséquent ce qu'on
voit dans les différents exemples que
j'ai cité hein que ce soit la Pologne la
Hongrie la Hongrie l'Italie ou la Suède
que ce soit des cadres législatifs
restrictifs ou non il y a toujours un
yatus là là aussi entre la loi et son
effectivité et les atteintes sont
multiples les les ressorts sont
exactement les mêmes et sont issus donc
de ces mouvements mouvements antidroit
qui trouvent leur traduction politique
au sein des partis d'extrême droite et
de la droite populiste et très largement
leur objectif principal c'est d'attaquer
en premier lieu les droits et la santé
sexuelle et reproductif des femmes ce
qui montre bien combien ces droits-là
sont fragiles et pour pour conclure
c'est pour cette raison que les
élections européennes de juin 2024 vont
être là aussi cruciale et déterminante
et va nécessiter la mobilisation de
toutes et tous parce que c'est dans ces
enceinteslà aussi que les mouvements
antidroits trouvent leur traduction et
arrivent à peser dans les dans les
décisions et c'est pour cette raison que
un ensemble l'ensemble des associations
féministes souhaite que l'IVG soit
inscrit dans la Charte européenne des
droits fondamentaux et un autre élément
que je souhaitais aussi mentionner c'est
la question de la R régulation face à la
régulation des plateformes et notamment
des des réseaux sociaux face à ces face
à ces mouvements parce que là aussi
c'est l'un des lieux sur lesquels il
prospère de manière assez massive en
usant de
désinformation notamment en utilisant
des sites Internet qui ont toute
l'allure de sites gouvernementaux or or
ces sitesl usent de désinformation ils
font en sorte par le biais notamment de
Li d'écoute notamment de numéro de
numéro de téléphone où les femmes
peuvent appeler ou tout simplement en
véhiculant des fausses informations pour
dissuader les femmes d'avorter et ça
c'est aussi un des éléments sur laquelle
sur lequel l'Union européenne doit
absolument se mobiliser d'ailleurs en
France il y a un délit d'entrave à l'IVG
qui avait été adopté d'entrave à l'IVG
numérique qui a été adopté en 2017 sur
lequel il faudrait largement s'inspirer
au niveau européen
merci
merci avant de vous redonner la parole
parce que je crois que vous avez des des
compléments à ajouter en fonction des
propos qui ont été tenus autour defin
dans la succession est-ce qu'il y a des
questions colombe brossell sénatrice de
Paris merci beaucoup bonjour à à toutes
et tous et merci à madame la Présidente
et aux animatrices
et non que des animatrices ce matin
d'ailleurs pour ce ce début de colloque
absolument passionnant j'avais une
question vous avez
évoqué au moins pour les deux premiers
intervenants puis finalement aussi
Amandine clavot la question de
l'entrisme dans les institutions qu'elle
soit internationale ou ou européenne et
je je me demandais s'il y avait à
l'échelle soit européenne soit
internationale d'ailleurs des stratégies
d'entrisme dans le milieu scolaire qu'il
soit d'ailleurs milieu scolaire ou
universitaire euh parce que j'ai en en
mémoire quelques stratégies extrêmement
françaises euh
dentrisme dans dans le milieu scolaire
euh qui euh mais exactement dans dans la
droite ligne de de ce que vous décriviez
monsieur data partant d'autres sujets
euh finalement arrivaient extrêmement
rapidement euh à la dénonciation euh et
euh du du droit euh à à l'avortement et
donc je voulais savoir si c'était des
phénomènes qu'on retrouvait dans dans
d'autres pays et comment est-ce que ils
avaient été plus ou moins d'ailleurs
contrecarré dans dans ces différents
pays
merci c'est tout pour aujourd'hui merci
d'avoir suivi ces débats organisés par
la délégation aux droits des femmes des
débats que vous pouvez évidemment
retrouver en Riplay ou sur notre
plateforme numérique
www.publicsenat.fr merci encore pour
votre fidélité et très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes
[Musique]
parlementaires